Y ¿qué hacés de repente
cuando en un campamento científico
te asignan un grupo con tres amigos,
te dan un pedazo de hilo
y la consigna de calcular
el ancho de un arroyo?
Seguro se ponen a discutir y tratan
de ver qué hacen con el hilo,
cruzan el arroyo mil veces,
tratan de ver cuántas veces
puede entrar el hilo en ese arroyo,
no sé... se mojan y se cansan seguro.
En una de esas, muerta de frío,
agotada, y encima, toda empapada,
me pregunté si no había
una forma de calcular ese ancho
sin tener que mojarme más.
Y entonces, me paré en la orilla
y comencé a observar.
Y entendí que parada ahí,
se formaban tres distancias:
la de mis pies hacia mis ojos,
la de mi vista hacia la otra orilla,
y de la esa orilla
hacia la cual yo estaba parada.
Y me acordé.
¡Soh-cah-toa!
(Risas)
Un conocimiento básico
de trigonometría
que hasta ese momento
parecía algo innecesario,
estaba ahí brindándome la respuesta
para una problemática en tiempo real.
Y por más simple
que haya parecido esta situación,
el proceso mental que tuve
que hacer en ese momento
fue particularmente diferente a cualquier
cosa que había hecho en mi vida.
Porque fue algo propio.
Fue genuino.
Y a partir de este momento
se despertó algo en mí,
que se ve que se había dormido,
por el simple hecho de creer
que yo no podía.
Pero esa vez pude,
y me agarró esta locura
por tratar de conocer más
sobre las cosas y sobre la realidad.
Así que no paré de buscar otras
experiencias parecidas a este campamento.
Me fui al Instituto Balseiro,
convencí a mis amigos de la escuela
para armar un destilador de agua solar
para un concurso del Conicet.
Me metí en más becas, olimpíadas,
y campamentos para seguir aprendiendo.
Y así que, a lo largo del año,
me dan el título de
"la chica ciencia" de la escuela.
Pero me pasó esto.
Me saqué un 7 en casi todas las materias.
Supongo que fue
porque fui creciendo, ¿no?
Digo.
Es normal que se vayan perdiendo
estos intereses a lo largo del tiempo.
Y más cuando sos chico, que de repente
llegás con un nuevo mundo,
lleno de obligaciones
y cosas que te quitan el tiempo
para lo que vos considerabas esencial.
Miren, durante todos
nuestros años de secundaria,
para poder eximir
todas las materias y pasar de año,
a todos los chicos de la Argentina
se nos pide sacar más de un 6 o un 7.
Y yo ahora me acuerdo que de chiquita
tenía esta idea de la escuela
como un lugar exclusivo para aprender
y no parar de maravillarme
con cosas nuevas.
Yo soñaba con ser astronauta,
con ser científica,
me acuerdo que con mis amigas
nos poníamos a jugar a ser
quienes íbamos a ser de grandes.
Mi amiga Rocío siempre
se ponía a dibujar,
diciendo que alguna vez iba a ser
dibujante de películas animadas.
Hoy, Rocío tiene casi 19 años
y empezó el traductorado de inglés.
¿Qué pasó durante esos 10, 11 años
de vida con ese sueño?
Seguramente creció, cambió de idea,
se dio cuenta de que esto realmente
no le gustaba, no era lo suyo.
Le pregunté y su respuesta
fue algo así como:
"lo que pasa es que el diseño de animación
en 3D tiene mucha matemática.
Y yo siempre me la llevo.
En cambio, en inglés,
siempre me saqué buenas notas.
Me es más fácil".
Y esto es así,
porqué resulta que la escuela
es la única referencia oficial
que tenemos los chicos
sobre nuestro rendimiento
intelectual y académico.
Y este es el resultado que puede tener
una simple calificación
dentro del contexto del sistema educativo:
no dedicarte a lo que te apasiona.
Porque no solo te sacás un 3 o un 4,
sos un 3 o un 4.
Y vas a seguir siendo ese 3 o ese 4.
Las calificaciones nos terminan
clasificando del 1 a 10.
Vos, chico 10, vos, sos mejor que todos.
Vos 1, y andá preparándote
para la que te espera.
Ahora, esta paradoja de ser
la chica ciencia y a la vez ser un 7,
me hizo caer en cuenta
de que, en realidad,
si terminás la escuela y encima
te animas a seguir
una carrera universitaria,
es muy probable que caigas en todo eso
que una vez nos enseñaron.
Hacés un balance
de las mejores notas que tuviste
o de las materias que más fáciles
te resultaron aprobar,
y simplemente buscás una carrera
que junte todo esto.
Entonces, muchas veces, lo que aprendemos
a pensar en la escuela es algo así como:
"si me es fácil sacar
unas buenas notas en esto,
seguro me gusta, por lo tanto,
es a lo que me debería dedicar".
Y durante lo que te queda de secundaria,
te enfocás simplemente en aprobar.
Termina pasando que los alumnos
aprendemos a ser alumnos.
Y a responder únicamente
con lo que se nos pide.
Pero, aprender de verdad,
¿dónde queda esto?
Requirió mucho esfuerzo entender
que yo era más que mi nota.
Que soy más que estos sietes.
Y cuando lo hice, mi notas
no cambiaron mucho.
Ahora lo que sí cambió,
es que empecé a aprender.
Pero ¿hasta qué punto podés
rebelarte y descuidar tus notas?
Digo, sí, podés evadirlas,
diciembre, marzo, previas,
pero si tu revolución
te sale mal, repetís de año.
No podemos hacer esto solos.
Necesitamos ayuda.
El sistema educativo necesita un cambio.
Yo les puedo asegurar
que la pasión y el interés
que tiene esa chica, Rocío,
mi amiga, por el dibujo,
vale muchísimo más que un 3
o un 4 en cualquier materia.
La escuela debería ser ese lugar
que nos enseña pensar.
A buscar eso que tanto nos enamora.
A ser de la manera que queremos ser,
y no la que nos dicen
los números que somos.
Hoy, mi boletín seguirá
diciendo que soy un 7, sí.
Mis compañeros, mis docentes
y mi establecimiento educativo
seguirán teniendo esta contradictoria
"chica ciencia" llena de sietes.
Pero para mí, soy más que un número.
Ahora, las calificaciones,
¿son algo realmente útil, necesarias?
No sé.
Pero mostrarnos durante todo
nuestro proceso educativo
que somos y podemos
muchísimo más que estos números,
estoy convencida que eso
es algo indispensable.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)